a somewhat's controversial Legacy and a
lifetime spent on the public eye Jerry
Springer might be gone but he won't soon
be forgotten Jerry Springer was a TV
icon for decades best known for his
self-titled talk show that kicked off in
1991. Springer himself would admit the
show change pop culture for better and
worse ushering in other shows of his ilk
that could affectionately be referred to
as trash TV the show was synonymous with
the 1990s but some may be surprised to
learn that it aired new episodes all the
way until 2018 but even when the show
ended Springer didn't leave television
he had another show lined up called
Judge Jerry where he took on legal cases
and ran for three seasons in March 2022
the TV personality spoke about how his
other series just didn't hit the same
way as Jerry Springer and covid-19 and
its social distancing policies didn't
help matters he told the New York Post I
was talking to parties that were
thousands of miles away wherever the
suits were filed was where we put the
cameras and you've got that delay a new
audience and me sitting in front of a
green screen it wasn't what I first
imagined but there was another issue
Springer found himself up against trying
to make Judge Jerry work with so many
episodes of Jerry Springer produced over
the decades it isn't hard to still catch
an episode if you have cable reruns
still air on syndication which lightly
netted Springer a nice paycheck of
residuals every so often but also
hampered his efforts to expand into
other series covered played a role in
the demise of Judge Jerry but he was
also His Own Worst Enemy as he went on
to tell the New York Post in most
markets they still run the Jerry
Springer Show thus been holding on and
there's only so much of me that a normal
human being can take it was a
containment issue if I was going to be
so crazy on that show how can I suddenly
be serious on the bench okay I'm putting
like health happiness peace and
prosperity in the room so you can all
feel that there's only so much Jerry
Springer can take and when it came to
end Judge Jerry Springer fully
understood why it had to happen he
continued to say I enjoyed doing Judge
Jerry no question but the industry isn't
based on gee are you having fun doing it
it wasn't making the money it was making
in the beginning I totally get it the
success of one show doesn't necessarily
translate to another so in 2022 the show
was canceled after three seasons when
the New York Post interview was
conducted in 2022 Jerry Springer was
obviously looking back on his life and
figuring out what it all meant you could
spend a long time debating the merits of
his show and what it did for the culture
at large but for Jerry his hit series
wasn't even his biggest accomplishment
he elaborated the greatest job I ever
had was being Mayor of Cincinnati and if
God came to me and said you can do one
thing and you can do it for your
lifetime I would have chosen that Legacy
is a complex question especially when it
comes to public figures even Springer
admitted that most people aren't
remembered a couple of decades after
they pass but that really wasn't what he
was angling for he just wanted to be
there for his family the wasn't things
to be remembered by your kids and your
grandkids if they'd love me and remember
me and I've been a good role model for
them that's all that matters even though
Judge Jerry ended sooner than Springer
probably would have liked his legacy in
the realm of Television is secure Jerry
Springer died in April 2023 but as he
put it himself his legacy will remain as
long as a crazy show keeps going I'll be
a part of the fabric of our memories of
our culture
[Music]
thank you